[Music]
there's another big sequel right around
the corner cannot wait for this one
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 I hope
you're ready it'll be here any minute
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 picks up
just a couple of months after the first
movie Peter quill aka star-lord is the
guy who's going to take care of this
band of misfits and be the quote-unquote
leader of this group of heroes
that's intense the Guardians gang is
back and that means lots of action
buying on wires Chris Pratt's like me
scruffier stunt double oh and new dad
Bradley Cooper as the voice of Rocket
Raccoon hey we're not looking at you
funny you got anger issues mature
yourself but the character we love
adorable baby group voiced by Vin Diesel
I am Groot Congress Groot uncle I love
the gentle giant aspect of Chris offered
up a tour of the Guardian Sat via the
charity auction site amazed here we are
with our designers these men are amazing
and also very open to collaboration my
idea is yeah I design costumes - I'm not
gonna show me any of the props no I know
I know see how they film me and then
seamlessly transport me to another
universe what the pyramids
am I in Egypt now what another of the
world's wonders but special effects
aside the best part for Chris was
getting to work with his man-crush Kurt
Russell who the hell are you I'm your
dad Peter there was a father-son
relationship here that I thought was
very relatable and very interesting he's
a legit stud he was a professional
baseball players a pilot a father and
outdoorsman I asked him if he'd be my
dad in real life and I'm still waiting
to hear back
[Music]
you